los crean y esperan poder mantener
abiertos en las próximas horas unos 10
corredores humanitarios en diez ciudades
del país corredores humanitarios que
precisamente tienen que servir para la
evacuación de los civiles de las zonas
más afectadas del penn del país por las
bombas del ejército ruso ahora nos
encontramos en la estación de trenes de
libia en esta estación está recibiendo
una enorme cantidad de personas personas
precisamente que están huyendo de
aquellas bombas y que esperan poder
tomar algunos de los trenes que de aquí
salen en dirección de la frontera con
polonia de ahí estas personas cuentan
con alcanzar otros países de la unión
europea en el que resguardarse hemos
entrevistado alguna de estas personas
entre ellos hay también estudiantes
universitarios que se encontraban en
programas de intercambio pero también
hay muchísimos niños madres que han
huido de bombas que han caído incluso
los últimos días y que finalmente en las
próximas horas cuentan con encontrar un
sitio seguro en el que pasar la noche